hello everyone i'm wenjin zen from
microsoft research asia leading the
video analytic research that powers
multiple microsoft products such as
azure cognitive services microsoft
office and microsoft dynamics 365.
welcome to the to work human-like visual
learning and reasoning track at the 2021
microsoft research summit
as reported in the media a big
data-driven approach to artificial
intelligence also known as ai has its
limitations
we have seen examples of this where
models fail to perform when applied to a
new setting that has not been seen
during training
or the event of prohibitive labeling
costs and delays
as a result researchers are beginning to
move from a purely big data driven
approach also called narrow ai
towards general ai where systems can
effectively leverage prior knowledges
such as concepts and relationships the
way humans do
this transition is critical as it will
significantly help develop ai theory and
address the problems encountered in the
practical applications of ai such as
interpretability complexity scalability
and data heterogeneity
microsoft is committed to investing
participating in and leading this effort
for example we have developed large
powerful and efficient pre-trained
visual and visual language models that
when coupled with transfer lending have
helped significantly improve our
products and state of art ai systems
you'll have a chance to learn about some
of that in today's program
this track is designed to facilitate an
exchange of new ideas provide a
community building opportunity for
researchers in the emerging field of
general ai and share inspiration for
promising new directions
we have a total of five technical
sections in this track
we begin with two keynote speeches by
professor ima from uc berkeley and
microsoft senior principal research
manager cassiod ecuchi who have
discussed two different approaches to
determine the deep learning the white
box approach which interprets deep
networks from the perspective of data
compression and a small data top-down
approach which aims to build a robot
system that can understand from a small
number of human observations what a
human is doing and map it to its own
actions
we'll then have two sections on the
topics of learning for interpretability
and few shot and zero shot learning and
reasoning each with three speakers
these two sections will shed light on
how to achieve interpretable learning
and human-like learning and reasoning
after the break we'll continue with the
stimulating panel discussion about what
computer vision will look like the next
decade
the panel will be moderated by professor
xilin chen from the chinese academy of
sciences who will be joined by four
prominent panelists
we'll conclude with the technical
section on model generalization and
adaptation the different data domains
and different downstream tasks which is
critical for practical applications
without further ado please enjoy the
program